as you know a couple of months ago the
batgirl movie got strangely cancelled
there's been a few rumors about why
generally that the movie was just that
bad they had to but there might be
another slightly darker reason
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so there's been a lot going on with
warner brothers in the last few months
the old company of warner media 18t and
discovery inc have been merged
now we have this new company warner
brothers discovery they own hbo max for
example
they also own warner brothers studios
there's been a lot going on behind the
scenes a lot of turmoil that we've just
not been able to see
but one thing we have been able to see
and one thing that really just shows us
what is going on and gives us a hint
about what's going on in warner brothers
was the cancellation of batgirl now as
you know if you're a regular sidetracker
there's a couple of people i speak to
but one person in particular does tend
to have
their thumb on what's going on and what
rumors are bouncing around hollywood
now this person actually used to work
for mgm but now works for a another
company an agency that gets to hear lots
of what's going on over the next week or
two i'm going to be giving you an
insight into some of the things he's
been telling me as i had a nice
almost an hour and a half chat with him
yesterday and i'm going to be working
through some of those rumors
the first big rumor though was this
batgirl story the general consensus was
when this news hit that it was a very
strange one
filming of the movie had already
virtually finished they'd already spent
18 million dollars on the production
david zaslaff came in as a new ceo of
discovery inc and cut it almost
immediately but the really strange thing
was that even though most of the
principal photography was finished they
didn't want to push on and finish
production and at very least show it on
hbo max
or they'd have done some reshoots and
get the movie back on track but where do
the rumors come from that the movie was
just so bad they couldn't even do that
well when these films are being produced
it's very common for these films to get
early screenings they have select
audiences they have an early screening
they ask them what they think of the
movie
when they come back and say it's a load
of rubbish that generally triggers some
reshoots and they try to rejig the film
or re-edit the movie somehow and try to
basically make the film better but
that's not what they did in this case in
this case they decided to completely
shelve the movie they're not even going
to show it on hbo max now i asked this
person i speak to why would they do that
and he did actually say well you've got
to remember that the principal filming
isn't all of the spending you've then
all got all the post-production stuff
and that's horrendously expensive too so
it may just be
that david zaslav decided let's just cut
our losses
this film is not good enough and we're
not going to spend another 50 million
dollars on it so let's just
scrap it so i asked is is that what
happened in this case they just decided
to cut their losses he says well no
um according to whispers around the
industry
there was a bit more to it than that
by the way if you're new to the channel
don't forget to like subscribe hit the
bell notification share the video
wherever hell you want and you can even
hit the join button because that really
supports the channel if you enjoy the
content also go to side trek.com for
lots of merchandise opportunities this
person that i speak to
spoke to somebody that was actually very
close to some of the meetings that
happened around this and actually was in
a meeting with david zaslaff was also
present
he says
that there were two major topics of
conversation when they were discussing
whether to just shelve the project
altogether
the first one was
the success and critical success of the
batman the dceu over the last few years
has
wandered to say the least i actually
really liked man of steel when the first
superman returned but if you look at the
tone of that movie compared to the tone
of the later superman movies
particularly the zack snyder's justice
league film they're very very different
even compared to batman vs superman a
film that other than that one scene
why'd you say that name other than that
um it's actually really good i really
love that movie i love the batman versus
superman fighter for example i just
thought it was wicked aquaman without
jason momoa
would have bombed
that film is actually not a good film
it's it's it's it badly made the special
effects are terrible the storyline is
random it it looks like a cw tv show but
just bigger
and the only thing that saved that film
is that jason momoa is just amazing in
it and he's just
a lovable actor everybody loves jason
mower and he saved that movie completely
so
when they were having these meetings
the new ceo basically said where does
batgirl fit in with the direction we
want to take the dc
they're looking at the batman movie and
the distinct style change of that film
compared to the rest of the dc
and they basically said where does
batgirl fit
if we're going that way with the dceu
now
batgirl feels way more like a cw tv show
or
something that we'd have done five years
ago it doesn't feel like
where we want to take the project in the
dc universe now
but then the conversation took a
slightly darker turn
and they started talking about how
people would react to the movie
and the conversation of woke came up
now as you know if you're a regular
sidetracker i hate that term
um
the term originally means being awake to
racial inequality and it has been
appropriated and twisted by a lot of
people to mean
lots of different things there
but
the people
i would like to think a loud minority of
people that genuinely believe hollywood
is woke and that this is a massive
problem have been getting steadily
louder and louder what's she hulk
in almost every episode
they have poked fun at people that keep
shouting about woke
they in the last episode in particular
um it's mentioned a couple of times and
she's she's talking about hey wong's
back on that'll quiet twitter down this
week so that's what marvel have decided
to do they've decided to just laugh at
the situation
david zazlav though seems to have a
slightly different opinion
now leslie grace is the actress that was
fronting this movie she was batgirl and
she is of latino descent she's also
though probably in this situation worse
a woman
the conversation
apparently in this meeting did go along
the lines of the woke community are
going to hate this
they're going to point out that batgirl
is a white girl in the comics and
they're going to point out that anyway
she's a mary sue and apparently the film
did make men at times look a bit stupid
this movie
isn't very good but we could fix it
this movie doesn't really fit with where
we're going but we could just put it on
hbo max
but this movie will get a crapload of
hate from the work community
and
do they really want that at the moment
they have basically wasted the last 10
years of the dc there where they should
have been created a massive franchise
like marvel but instead they've
squandered the opportunity
the relative success of the batman and
the critical success of the batman
really shows them a new direction and
the batgirl just doesn't fit
but more importantly they really don't
want the intention of the woke shouters
and this film
everything that's going on lord of the
rings that really showed them that they
do not want that attention so what do i
think
i think if the movie was just that bad
and going in the wrong direction for
where they want to take the dc
so they decided to
scrap it and shelve it
um i actually think that's really brave
i think that's them saying look we've
made a mistake we need to go in a
different direction now sod the money
our reputation is more important let's
just let's just scrap it and let's start
again i think that's incredibly brave
and
only to be honest a new president a new
ceo into a company could probably get
away with it
but
then they have the conversation about
woke
and from what i'm being told
it seemed to be
that that was the deciding factor they
basically thought the film's not great
but we could fix it if this is
we can fix it um but the woke stuff we
can't fix
we can't change the color
and the gender of the leading star and
that's all people are gonna see
and this loud minority are going to
scream at us and
that's some publicity we don't want now
that comes across as cowardice to me one
of the things that davis assaf said
um in a statement talking about this was
that we're not going to put projects out
that we don't believe in
now a lot of people said that was
because the film was just so bad they
didn't their hearts weren't behind it
and they just didn't think it was good
enough but there's another way of
looking at it
maybe
their warner brothers is being taken
maybe a slightly more conservative route
and by believing they meant that they
just didn't believe
the way the film was portraying the main
character
if that's the case
then i'm really worried where warner
brothers are going to take future
projects
please get into the comments and tell me
what you think about this news that woke
killed the batgirl movie
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker and hitting the join button that
really supports the channel
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you